the Joe Rogan experience this is sober
October right so me and Ari and Bert and
Tom we have this thing yeah in October
so it's and you're reading a book it's
on right now yeah we've read 500 pages
that's good well you were eating Bert
can't read
Bert's sitting down with a but he's not
reading is so hilarious I don't believe
it he's see it's on the honor system so
I think he's probably gonna throw an
audio book on and just lie yeah you
can't no I heard you guys talking about
that no audio because you can space out
you know like listening to a podcast no
no no yeah he's got a he's got a nice
two-page right and then I want a book
report I haven't even started I haven't
started any book I'm listening to a
bunch of books on tape which is most of
the way I consume books but um can I
recommend a book to you please okay get
ready I'm ready
it's called Cupid's poisoned arrow mmm
and it's about how orgasms are ruining
us and our relationships and our
happiness and it talks about how I'm all
for this right now and it's a wild
concept and I've only read three pick
three chapters of this book so just I
don't have all the information but what
I do know is that orgasms are this rush
of like blood whatever your your limbic
system is all fired up when you have an
orgasm and everything we do in our lives
to like have stability and you know kind
of lower anxiety and fight depression is
about balancing that and not spiking it
ever so orgasms are throwing us off
constantly and we're not supposed to be
having this many of them men men should
here's the thing though about men and
orgasms is that they they want to run
right after they come it's in your DNA
to get the [ __ ] out of there because as
a caveman there wasn't you can't make
something pregnant twice so once you
came on to the next teepee - [ __ ] the
girl's cousin that you just like it
wasn't about you weren't gonna stay in
cuddle [ __ ] run let me tell you
something yeah that's not really true
what it's only true
if you don't actually like the person if
you only attracted them in horny
if you're only attracted to them in
horny but you don't like them as a
person yeah once you call me like oh my
god oh you're out of here
but if you like them as a person once
you can't me like that was great they
just want to hang out I am actually a
man I do trust you
but I also think that there you would
want to hang out even more if you didn't
come that's not true
really yes here's my thing though I've
had a lot of instances this book spoke
to me because I cannot trace what
happens between a guy liking me and not
in slow fading me then to an orgasm
you're an intense person okay you're
very smart you're also very ambitious
and without any derogatory intent saying
this at all you're a lot of work but
doesn't mean you're bad just means
you're you're a powerful person you got
a lot going on yeah they're intense yeah
you're thinking all the time you know
your question my things hmm you question
yourself you question this and that and
you're just you're a lot of work yeah
some guys just can't [ __ ] deal and
maybe the right guy can you got to find
the right guy there's like everybody
this is my theory on human beings like
no one is for everybody there's not one
person out there that's the perfect fit
for everyone but if you find someone who
has your the right slots for your hands
like it fits in like this then you're
good but if it lands like this where
they have to things like they have big
tits and you know they like to [ __ ] but
yeah they're annoying and they talk too
much you're gonna it's not gonna work
yeah it's not gonna work but the problem
is men like men are horny all the time
they're attracted to women right and
then sometimes that horniness and that
attractiveness you get confused and
think you actually like the person and
you drain it seems like you're a liar
but you're not a liar at the time um
before you come you're being earnest but
then once you spooge you're like I gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
be yappy yap yap yap a nonsense talk I
got to get the [ __ ] away yeah
and then somebody's what I feel right
but it's your meeting the wrong people
some people would be perfect with fun
and funny Thanks
that's the thing I'm like what change
between meas us hanging out you liked me
and then I sucked your dick and now you
don't watch my Instagram stories anymore
okay you can't ask someone to wash your
instagrams no I'm not I'm not actually
asking that but it's like that's an
indication if someone likes you
why because I mean it's just it's just
me no watch any of my friends because I
love dearly I don't watch any of their
[ __ ] because you're not you're not
dating in on instagrams
I don't like I was you what I thought I
wouldn't Joe trust me okay I wouldn't
maybe you're too busy but here's here's
my but if you like that's how you show
you like someone now answer all them up
ok all people yeah hang out with them
you're nice to them when you see them I
don't want to watch you [ __ ] eat cake
on Instagram and watch your [ __ ]
boomerangs with a fork full of cake yeah
you're right so not interested in that
I'm busy
yeah [ __ ] to do and time is super
valuable for me I'm not watching
anybody's [ __ ] instruments no one
then watch them watch it's an action
that's how I know when someone likes me
if a guy's face keeps popping up
underneath my story and I'm like oh my
god he's watching my stuff to console
her works I didn't even know that's in a
lot of time that someone's watched your
Instagram story yeah so you can flip up
on them and see who's watching and I'll
speak to your point watching a lot to
watch them have watched them and now if
a lot of times a guy will be too busy or
I'll be too busy but I need I need to
let this guy know that I like him so
I'll just flip through them very quick I
won't even watch him but I want my face
to pop up so he knows I'm interested
it's just a way to be like hey I'm into
you and it's just a way to indicate now
it happened it's happened to me with a
couple guys that I've really liked that
they're in they're interested and then
after we hook up no more and and it's
not because I wasn't good at what I was
doing I really don't think it's that or
like why do you have an idea of what it
was without asking um well I have asked
and a lot of times
or one time they've said and then I
think it's actually tells me know a
couple times actually I I get there too
vulnerable with me and then I've seen
too much in terms of like they've let me
in in a way emotionally that they've
never let a woman in before and then
they're like there I remind them of the
fact that they might have cried with me
or something and then they don't want to
be around it anymore that sounds like
what I would say if I'm trying to get
rid of somebody really yeah I don't
think that's true
[Applause]